the film begins in a dystopian 1985
Miami where crime is at its peak a group
of local gangsters get into an argument
with a cop for no apparent reason when
they are asked to identify themselves
one of them flips his skateboard under
the police car and sends it flying
Defying Gravity as we know it the
gangsters then shoot at the car and make
it explode hence killing the officer
inside the city of Miami is swarming
with gangsters who kill and kidnap
whoever they want it's almost as if GTA
Vice City has been adapted into a movie
in a nearby arcade two men lose a video
game and call the machine stupid in turn
the machine flashes a curse at them and
starts protesting electric waves go down
its body suddenly making it come to life
as the Geeks watch it in awe it flips
them off and blasts their heads
following that the machine exits the
arcade and goes on a rampage killing
everyone and dismantling everything in
its way several crashed cars and
destroyed buildings later a cop car
comes to the scene and tries fighting it
however he is easily overpowered by the
mechanical beast when it runs out of
coins and starts dying it steals some
cash from a nearby parking meter and
continues ambushing everyone on its way
at last the cops announced a state of
emergency and the only solution is to
call Kung Fury Kung Fury is the best cop
in the city known for being the chosen
one in the art of kung fu currently he
is with his girlfriend enjoying some
alone time upon getting the message
about the manic machine he immediately
jumps off a building and lands right in
his sports car by the time he reaches
the crime scene the machine is flipping
off a random dog on the road Fury slams
the car into it before sliding the
machine onto the ground the two then
indulge in a brutal fight which goes on
for hours at one point they somehow end
up hanging off of a flying helicopter
Fury is even slammed into a space
satellite but he bounces back and
continues the onslaught in the end he
finally emerges Victorious and the
arcade machine is dismantled then we are
taken to the past when Furious Journey
journey to becoming the best cop began
one night he and his partner are chasing
down a mysterious Kung Fu Master in the
line of duty they catch him as a team
proving that they are the best cop Duo
ever however what they don't know is
that Kung Fu man isn't a noob he slices
Fury's partner in half and kills him in
an instant before preparing to do the
same to him but just then Furious hit by
lightning and bitten by a Cobra at the
same time he falls unconscious and goes
to a Shaolin School in his dreams for
years the school had been looking for
the one person who is able to fight in a
style called The Fury the chosen one
turned out to be Fury himself which is
how he got his name suddenly he wakes up
back in the alley with the Kung Fu
Master seconds away from killing him
this time he slams The Man to the wall
with a single kick proving that he is in
fact the chosen one ultimately the
criminal falls into an oil tanker and
blows up while Fury does a false split
nearby after everything calms down he
goes to the wreckage and takes a piece
of the criminal's cloth as a souvenir
promising to fight people like him to
maintain peace in his City in the
following scene Furious called to the
captain's office everyone is angry at
him for destroying an entire block of
housing to catch a single machine to
stop him from making the same mistake
again the captain assigns him with a
partner tricera cop who happens to be a
human with the head of a dinosaur
however Fury flat out refuses to work
with a partner after the last one died
years ago hence he resorts to quitting
the job altogether as he is about to
leave the station the captain gets a
call from an unknown number the person
on the other end is Adolf Hitler who is
also a Kung Fu Enthusiast he threatens
to put an end to everyone's lives and
starts shooting the phone it somehow
works and an array of bullets are
showered throughout the station killing
the captain and several other cops
fortunately before any more harm is done
Fury returns and destroys the phone with
some impeccable strikes following this a
flashback of Hitler's life shows us that
he was a Kung Fu champion in the 1940s
he wanted to Master the art of Fury and
be the chosen one for that he employed
an entire Army and called himself the
Kung fuhrer I'd have gone with Adolf
Hitmonchan however he never managed to
master the art and disappeared one day
out of embarrassment but it turns out
that he somehow time traveled into the
future to kill the chosen one AKA Fury
now the only way to stop him is to
return to the 1940s and kill him when
his army is still Rising there is only
one small problem a time machine hasn't
been invented yet in 1985 as Fury dwells
on what he should do next a guy with a
small mustache and a mullet haircut
steps forward and reveals himself as
hacker man he puts on his special glove
inputs some codes in his computer and
miraculously creates a time machine Fury
is eventually hacked back in time but
the machine malfunctions and he reaches
further into the past than he wanted to
he realizes this when he sees an animal
that had already been extinct named the
laser Raptor he is about to be lasered
by the Raptor when suddenly someone
blows it up it turns out to be a girl
with a large machine gun who is riding a
giant wolf she introduces herself as
barbariana and reveals that they are in
the Viking age soon they are joined by
another gun-wielding girl named Katana
and the three decide to go to a hill to
talk upon being told how Fury got here
the girls are willing to help him they
do not have the power required to send
him to the future but they know just the
right person for the task so Katana
summons the god of thunder and an
enormous Thor appears in front of them
he flexes his muscles and brags about
his workout routine before asking them
what is wrong when asked if he can make
the time rip in space Thor moves his
hammer and does so in seconds before he
leaves barbariana asks Fury if he will
ever return the two cents chemistry
between them and to decide to keep in
touch through phone calls however since
this world doesn't have phones Fury
somehow creates one and advertises it to
barbariana after listing out all the
features that it provides he wishes them
farewell and walks into Nazi Germany at
first glance the place doesn't look so
great two knots soldiers are sitting by
a tank talking about mustaches the Elder
One Compares the other guy's mustache to
the pubes and makes him cry after a
minute-long argument they look around
and see the tank is missing it turns out
that Fury is holding it above their
heads before they can run away he
smashes them and says thank you oh God
who writes this guy's jokes me at night
Hitler is giving a speech to a crowd of
thousands of Nazis who for some reason
are wearing gas masks he declares
himself to be the greatest Kung fuhrer
of all time and asks the crowd if he is
right he only moves on to the next
sentence once they affirm Hitler also
displays some awkward dance moves to wow
the audience everything is going well
until suddenly a loud bang is heard a
tank has come crashing through the
ceiling and seconds later Fury jumps to
the ground he approaches a Nazi Soldier
and says I'm going to disarm you before
proceeding to literally tear his arm off
then he planted on a gun and creates
helicopter Wings by spinning it this
strange device allows him to fly over
the crowd while shooting at everyone
inside night the fuhrer finally orders
his troops to get the Intruder but they
are hardly a match to the one and only
Kung Fury although he is surrounded by a
sea of enemies Fury fights them bravely
without being touched even once he
decapitates some with only a kick and
makes the others Fly Away into space
Hitler sees this and finally takes
action he brings out a machine gun which
was hidden inside his Podium and starts
firing at the crowd randomly many of his
own men are killed but Fury is also shot
several times to everyone's surprise he
drops to the ground and Hitler wins with
this all the Nazis erupt into loud
shears and celebrate their victory until
some loud thunder startles them the God
of Thunder drops from the sky making
everyone aware of his Magnificent
Presence simultaneously he is followed
by hackerman barbariana Katana a laser
Raptor and Fury's 2B police partner
Triceratop they collectively launch an
attack on the Nazi army and kill them
one after another the dinosaur defeats
half of the army with its laser eyes
barbariana and katana prove that they
are no less than any fighter Triceratop
and hackerman are driven by their love
for Fury but the one who kills the most
people is Thor after an intense battle
they abruptly stop and watch the last
Nazi fall to the ground now the only
enemy left is Hitler himself suddenly
hackerman notices that Fury is nowhere
to be seen they begin searching for him
and finally find his dead body on the
ground in the meantime an enraged fuhrer
releases his massive pet eagle which is
made of solid gold it immediately goes
to attack the group but is stopped by
the laser Raptor then we are taken into
a virtual world where a cartoon-like
fury is wandering around he meets a
giant Cobra who turns out to be a spirit
animal it is the same snake that bit
Fury the night he gained Eternal
knowledge and became the chosen one the
Cobra reveals that this is heaven and
the fury has died on Earth this means he
will get to continue living in luxury
and happiness for eternity however it is
far from what Fury wants he shows the
Cobra his ID and in assists that he has
to return to Earth because he is a
police officer when the Cobra still
refuses Fury glows red and rage he jumps
at the snake to kick it but right before
the hit the Cobra disappears after that
Furious sucked back into the world where
the eagle and the laser Raptor are still
quarreling it turns out that hackerman
hacked heaven and downloaded him back to
life nice Fury thanks him before turning
his attention to Hitler at first the
fuhrer pretends to be fuming but upon
realizing that he cannot win the fight
he changes his stance as the group of
herpes watch in awe what Hitler pretends
to be on their side he compares the red
background in the swastika to Fury's
clothes and says that they are like
brothers however before he can finish
his sentence Fury punches him in the
manhood and sends him flying he falls to
the ground helpless and finally Thor
crushes him with his hammer seconds
before he is crushed the eagle tries to
save him but he too suffers the same
fate when Thor takes the hammer off
nothing of Hitler and the eagle has left
this slightly surprises the group but
nonetheless they believe that the
enemies have been defeated and start
celebrating at last everyone turns to
Fury and inquires what next he replies
that he wants to return to the police
station because he has a lot of
paperwork to do the corny joke
surprisingly makes everyone burst out in
laughter the scene then Cuts back to the
opening scene where the arcade machine
is rampaging through Miami shortly after
Fury arrives in his sports car and
starts tussling he fights the machine
just like before and manages to kill it
in the end somewhere else in an alley
the eagle and the fuhrer appear out of
thin air it is then revealed that the
eagle was able to protect its master in
the past by teleporting them in the nick
of time now they are ready to avenge the
death of thousands of their comrades in
the last scene Fury notices that the
arcade machine has a swastika on its
side the look on his face says that he
knows Hitler is back subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching